if she gave it up in the early years for  free yeah why is it why is it necessary  for him to quote her now shouldn't he  also get access to it for free  um well I mean  why should he automatically get the  access to it for free because everybody  else had it for free so yeah I'm sure  I'm sure not every single person in the  world like do you know yeah  yeah  I ran through her yeah now it comes to  be your opportunity you might just be a  well-rounded guy yeah let's give an  example A lot of girls do do this like a  girl will see potential and value in you  so she wants to treat you like a proper  guy so I'm gonna withhold sex with me  because I want you to be my man yeah but  imagine I'm thinking bro you him him him  her yeah and now I'm the good guy that's  to me that's almost like a disrespect